what's been missing from some of my
criticisms of the way in which some
progressives have been activating since
the election on november eighth of our
first orange president some of the
criticisms have been missing specific
actions that progressives should be
taking over the next year or two what
should the playbook be for progressives
and that's exactly what i want to dig
into today obviously it's time to just
accept that Donald Trump is president
acknowledged that he in coalition with
the Republican House and the Republican
Senate and the soon to be conservative
Supreme Court have a lot of power right
now there's just no denying it we have
to work with that reality rather than
pretend it doesn't exist and that most
progressives are actually doing the
protesting is going to be a really
important aspect to keeping momentum and
enthusiasm if the focus of the protests
is on strategy and on pratt Ock's and
number one I already talked about this
yesterday the focus has to be something
other than identity politics I know a
lot of people agreed with me yesterday
some people disagreed with me I'm going
to skip that because that i did a rant
on that yesterday and let's get into
some other aspects of this number 1 i've
said this before I'll say it again when
Trump does something good we have to say
we agree with it now you know the whole
TP withdrawing us from TPP which I'll
talk about later it's just optics TPP
was dead anyway and I'll get to that but
in any case if it's progressives we
don't want TPP then we still recognize
that withdrawing the u.s. from TPP is
the right thing Trump is talking about
making sure everyone has health care yes
the people he's appointing to figure out
what the replacement to Obamacare will
be our total crony capitalist of crony
capitalist I don't know what else to
call them and more than likely whatever
the replacement is going to be a big
boon to big corporations and profits but
we still need to at least until it's
clear that the proposal is not going to
be good say hey you said you wanted
health care for everybody we're going to
hold you to that because we agree with
that
acknowledging that there is a threat
worldwide from radical Islamic terrorism
even though Trump takes it too far even
though in the u.s. most terrorism is
committed not by Muslim extremists but
by white men we still can say okay that
is an issue in the same way that
President Obama said that that is an
issue and sometimes ostensibly
non-interventionist ideas from Trump
about some things even if for the wrong
reasons can we sort of agreed upon by
progressives but what about the activism
let's dig into that number one let's
start passing ranked choice voting at
the state level this is also known as
Instant Runoff voting main did it this
helps third parties enter viability
without a risk to the more mainstream
liberal or centre-left politician
national popular vote initiative within
states our system gives disproportionate
power to rural voters and a popular vote
system would require candidates to cater
to the needs of us voters more evenly
take a look at this picture which I'm
going to put up for our TV audience this
is a map of post convention campaign
events by Trump and Clinton as you can
see we've got an electoral vote but this
doesn't look too evenly spread to spread
to me the ideapad of the electoral vote
is we're not going to give tons of power
to the cities and having politicians
focus there well they just focus in
other arbitrary places that's the point
of the electoral college you only have
to appeal to a certain number of states
being Ohio Pennsylvania Florida and
that's where the elections decided no
doubt eleven states have already entered
into the National popular vote
interstate compact and if we get 270
electoral votes total there we
essentially have pushed a national
popular vote we have to work for voter
turnout increase low voter turnout
almost always benefits Republicans or
the more conservative candidate in the
election if you've got two Republicans
or two Democrats in a primary for
example we can work on this through
registration through organizations or on
your own and we've got to fight voter ID
voter fraud in the way that Republicans
say it is a problem people voting twice
people lying about their identity etc
it basically doesn't exist I don't
remember the number pad I don't know if
you do but it's such a small problem the
number of instances of that would not
make any difference in an election and
one of the instances that we covered a
voter fraud during the 2016 election
would actually came from a trump
supporter that's right who was trying to
prove some kind of point who even knows
what the point is the US geo a gov has
determined that photo ID laws reduced
turnout by two to three percent as we've
covered photo IDs are called free but
they're really not without cost and it
is a major issue contact state
legislators urge Congress to restore the
full protections of the Voting Rights
Act this is something you can work on at
the federal and state level donate to
and volunteer with nonprofits with
progressive mission this can include the
ACLU this can include Planned Parenthood
this includes the ADL the eff electronic
freedom frontier frontier foundation I
forget exactly what eff is they work on
electronic freedom the National
Immigration Law Center people for the
American Way human rights campaign there
really are organizations that are not
just out there kind of doing something
where you can volunteer and actually
have an impact and elections activism
over the next two years let's first look
at what there is to work on in 2017 okay
we will start their governor's races in
Virginia and New Jersey we've got to be
involved in that five US House
Representative elections 15 major city
mayors we talked about how great
Republicans are at the local level city
mayors make a big impact and 220 state
legislators again state legislators
Republicans crush Democrats and
progressives at the state and local
level state legislators in concert with
city mayors and governors do a lot in
this country the president yes the
president has power but a lot of it is
happening at the state level and in 2018
and I know Pat is eager to comment
because these are issues you feel
strongly about in 2018 we've got 36
governor's races 33 us senatorial races
one
of the US Senate is up for re-election
every two years all 435 US House of
Representatives members and eighty
percent of state legislators even if
President Trump and a Republican Senate
and I would argue even a Republican
House maintain and after twenty eighteen
eighty percent of state legislators are
up for reelection you drastically
changed this country if you change the
balance of power at the state level yeah
and I know the media is trying to focus
now on the 2020 election because that's
kind of the horse race politics that we
have here yeah I think it's way too
early for that but we can still get the
pieces in motion absolutely as you say I
think it's 68 out of the 99 state
legislatures are in Republican control
it starts from the bottom up we got to
start working in those races because
that does play a big impact so this is
why it's so important what I said
yesterday let's see how much energy the
rism is three months when it's time to
get working in some of these because
some of these areas people turning out
awesome the distraction that I believe
was some of the identity politics stuff
okay disappointing but there's a lot to
work on here and then in the background
is the 2020 census and we've talked
about that before I mean if we're going
to fix congressional gerrymandering it's
going to happen after the 2020 census
and that is something that progressives
can also be involved in too early to get
into that right now but we're not that
far from starting to prepare for that
there is a lot to do here and I hope
you'll be involved